bonjour à tous
qui dans la salle utilisent le même mot
de passe sur plusieurs sites internet
d'accord qui utilisent principalement
gmail et facebook pour communiquer en
ligne
d'accord imaginez que vous sortiez de
chez vous le matin et que vous
retrouviez le facteur vous le voyez en
train de fouiller dans tous vos
courriers il lie tous vos courriers il
les photographie pour les garder pour
lui ce serait dingue n'est ce pas ce
n'est pas terminé
vous vous apercevez que la clé qui là
pour ouvrir vos boîtes aux lettres est
la même que celle de votre maison est la
même que celle de votre voiture
ainsi ils pourraient aller chez vous
quand vous n'êtes pas là et emprunter
votre voiture quand elle est au garage
ce serait carrément complètement dingue
votre facteur qui ressemblerait plutôt
un hacker et pourtant pour toutes les
personnes qui viennent de lever la main
précédemment ce que vous faites sur
internet est exactement l'équivalent de
ce que je viens de dire si vous gardez
le même mot de passe partout vous
laisser la porte ouverte un hacker qui
peut une fois qu'il a trouvé la bonne
combinaison aller sur tous vos autres
comptes
le meilleur moyen à ce moment-là et
d'utiliser ce qu'on appelle un
gestionnaire de mots de passe
pour ceux qui communiquent
principalement sur gmail et facebook
vous avez tous vous couriez qui sont
analysés toutes vos données à ce moment
là
les analyses sont faites et on retrouve
toutes les données que vous avez
conservé depuis longtemps avec tous les
mots clés
le meilleur moyen à ce moment-là et de
choisir une messagerie qui ne se gagnent
pas tous vos contenus
il ya ce qu'on appelle le retargeting
vous en avez peut-être entendu parler ce
sont des publicités ciblées qui
s'affiche sur votre écran selon les
recherches que vous avez fait ce sont
des publicités contextuelles ce genre de
publicité est intéressante mais on ne
sait jamais cela peut parfois conduire à
de mauvaises surprises
si jamais vous avez fait des recherches
pour faire un cadeau à votre conjoint et
que ce genre de publicités s'affichent
tout au long du mois
cinquante fois sur l'ordinateur familial
il est donc essentiel de faire attention
à ce que l'on appelle notre hygiène de
vie numérique
il s'agit de mesures que l'on peut
prendre pour protéger ses données
efficacement pourquoi nos données ont
autant de valeur parce que les données
que nous générons sont utilisés par les
services et les applications pour
valoriser nos profils il y à des données
cependant qu'ils n'avaient tout
simplement pas être marchande et surtout
lorsque nous ne le savons pas certains
d'entre nous ont déjà pris une carte de
fidélité dans un magasin quand nous
avons rempli le formulaire pour avoir
cette carte nous avons donné énormément
d'un fond d'informations personnelles ce
que nous savons moins c'est que nous
donner sont également scanner par
rapport à nos achats et nous sommes
catégoriser on sait par exemple si nous
sommes allergiques au gluten ou on peut
deviner quel est notre religion
si nous avons en plus cocher la case des
offres partenaires nous donner ont été
vendus à des sociétés que l'on ne
connaît pas dont on ignore le nombre et
à ce moment là la valeur de nos données
explose
car nous donner sont extrêmement
importantes elles ont beaucoup de valeur
vous êtes tous assis dans cette salle
sur un 2e objet qu'est le plus de valeur
il s'agit de votre téléphone portable
c'est devenu l'objet le plus enviable de
tous les temps la valeur de votre
téléphone est moindre que le contenu qui
lie à l'intérieur le contenu est devenu
plus important que le contenant en
italie en 2013
un étudiant a revendu six mois de ces
données de navigation sur internet
il les a vendues aux enchères les
enchères sont montées jusqu'à 2000
dollars nous sommes donc constamment
face à des données que l'on cède sans
savoir vraiment à qui et pourquoi
il existe un autre cas de piratage cette
fois ci ashley madison un site internet
qui a vu les données de ses 37 millions
de membres fuir du jour au lendemain
dans la nature
nom prénom adresse postale
photo email la totale c'était un site de
rencontres extra conjugales
nous avons donc un problème nos données
sont centralisées et nous sommes à la
merci de ceux qui les détiennent
ce sont tout d'abord ce qu'on appelle
les gaffes à google apple facebook
amazon mais aussi des centaines
d'intermédiaires dont nous nous
connaissons pas l'identité
face à ces problèmes nous avons
également des menaces nous avons une
sécurité aléatoires car nous ne savons
pas vraiment à qui nous confions nos
données nous avons une perte d'autonomie
car nous sommes dépendants de ces
prestataires et nous avons forcément une
perte de confiance qui en résulte face à
ces problèmes il nous faut donc des
solutions
du côté du législateur c'est assez
difficile car on ne sait pas vraiment le
temps qu'il peut prendre
il a souvent un peu de retard par
rapport à nos usages du côté de
l'utilisateur
bien qu'il puisse savamment protéger ses
données personnelles avec une bonne
hygiène de vie numérique
on ne peut pas non plus forcément lui
demander des miracles c'est donc du côté
de la technologie qu'il est possible de
faire quelque chose c'est la technologie
qui doit nous apporter la réponse
elle doit nous permettre de protéger nos
données efficacement voici le type de
données de réseau que nous avions dans
le passé c'était un réseau extrêmement
centralisé autour d'une seule source
voici le type de réseau que nous avons
aujourd'hui il est centralisé autour de
plusieurs sources
mais nous sommes toujours dépendant
d'elle et voici le réseau du futur
il s'agit d'une architecture entièrement
distribué dans laquelle nous sommes tous
acteurs et ne de ce réseau
c'est ça la clé vivre ensemble numérique
l' architecture décentralisée et
distribués dont je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui s'appelle la blocs chain il
s'agit d'une technologie de stockage et
de transmission d'informations
elle est transparente et sécurisée pour
tous elle n'a aucun organe de contrôle
aucun intermédiaire et il s'agit d'une
architecture distribuée dans laquelle
chacun peut être acteur avec les blocs
chaîne ce sont des petits blocs de
données qui sont créés une fois que ces
blocs de données sont créés ils
deviennent consultables mais non plus
modifiable tout ce qui est injecté dans
ces blocs de données et donc gravé à vie
dans le marbre numérique la blocs j'aime
peut nous permettre de changer
énormément de choses tout a commencé en
2009 avec le transfert d'argent
il est possible grâce à la belote shane
de transférer efficacement de l'argent
d'un point a à un point b dans le monde
entier 365 jours par an dans le monde
entier avec n'importe qui il est très
simple de le faire les transactions
prennent une quinzaine de secondes
cela a évolué nous pouvons désormais
grâce à la blog shane certifier les
données comme des diplômes des permis de
conduire des actes de naissance hla
blocs chaîne va pouvoir dans quelques
mois quelques années
remplacer un grand nombre
d'intermédiaires il y à encore plus
intéressant aujourd'hui nous allons
pouvoir aller vers ce que l'on appelle
les smart contracte les contrats
intelligent ce sont des contrats que
vous pouvez créer vous même sur lesquels
vous avez entièrement le pouvoir vous
décider des conditions vous n'êtes plus
dépendants d'un tiers
typiquement si quelqu'un vient chez vous
demain et que vous souhaitez les bergers
aujourd'hui vous êtes obligé de passer
par une plate forme d'hébergement mais
avec les contrats intelligent vous fixé
les conditions
imaginons que nous avions en nous avons
un voyageur qui vient dans notre
appartement pendant que nous sommes en
vacances
si jamais ce voyageur repart deux jours
avant le terme de ces vacances le
contrat s'ajustera automatiquement sans
aucune intervention
nous pouvons encore aller plus loin si
votre voyageurs laisse allumé
l'électricité tout le temps fait couler
des bancs tous les soirs vous vous
retrouveriez avec des factures un peu
salée à la fin du mois avec les contrats
intelligents nous pouvons basculer
automatiquement le nom du voyageur à la
place du vôtre pour vos factures de gaz
d'électricité et d'internet
le temps de sa présence dès lors qu'il
franchit le pas de votre porte
un troisième point dont je voudrais
parler concerne la gestion de nos
données avec les blocs chaîne cela
devient plus facile nos données ne sont
plus centraliser en un seul et unique
point elles sont volontairement
dispatchés en plusieurs points du réseau
cela renforce considérablement notre
sécurité nous avons donc la possibilité
de retrouver de la sécurité de
l'autonomie et donc forcément de la
confiance
la blocs chaîne permet de recréer cette
confiance qui nous manquait tant
puisqu'il s'agit du point central de
tous nos échanges sur internet nous
pouvons aller vers une société plus
équilibrée plus juste plus harmonieuse
dans laquelle chacun a un rôle à jouer
dans laquelle chacun est acteur et non
plus spectateur
je souhaite que nous puissions aller
vers une société qu'ils soient aidés et
non plus piloté par les données là blocs
chaîne peut nous permettre de faire cela
peut nous permettre de retrouver une
société plus sereine dans laquelle la
confiance est présente au quotidien
c'est cela que nous allons pouvoir faire
demain afin de changer positivement
notre rapport à la technologie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]